I went to welcome to this video playing
Maxie looky again that's funny and now
we go for London system yeah he takes
the pawn yes this is some critical line
so
okay let's let's try to focus them it's
pretty comparable to the notable with
with colors reversed b6 know then you
can take and go five if I guess as I
probably have to take first now will be
six mmm Bishop takes Bishop takes again
b5 not working mighty force may be an
idea for possible Queen f6 I've played
this myself with white that the line
with the capture so what is he doing
that he's just giving up material start
working
I'm just too tempted yeah I'm just too
tempted let's go for that maybe you can
try to trap my queen or something like
that it's going 8-4 okay I can take e
for now and hmmm I wonder 93-5 it's not
trapping my queen creek lane that's not
going to happen my ideas to go five now
limit is pieces and possibly Bishop is
six it doesn't have such a great square
for the Queen maybe you can do something
crazy my development is really bad so
something like I know castling short
that could be a move my queen is very
short on squares but if I take F 493 I
take everyone I mean I've got tons of
material them where I can't tons of
material is a bit a bit strong but some
material bishops is six seems uncritical
yeah that's the simple way to do it okay
but should be six was my idea asking me
about a square for the Queen
unfortunately I cannot take on before
now that would be cool but of course it
sir and still the chess rules you have
to follow mmm yeah Queen 82 what trade
Queens it's not so bad probably
I think it will trade queens and they've
come on we can also play Queenie for
cause and queen d 5 i'm really not sure
about Queenie to but maybe I'm okay
entry he trades he just trades I guess
we should be five now hmm yeah he has a
very interesting position therefore the
material I think I'm i want that Bishop
him so check before so force him to take
and go from them night if for maybe
alkyl group d three in this case Oh
interesting so let's just cover let's
just cover things he's got very strong
compensation with the pawns and term one
thing is pretty clear in blitz those
pawns are easier to play then the
material I'm going to exchange up for
that porn and but his his game is just
easy mb5 I will take that's good I have
to have to connect books can go be five
now
I guess ok a five
yeah he's just better here what can you
do no it's just better him they played
that probably pretty well i'm not sure i
mean i don't think that Queen f6 that
that allowing this is good for white but
it's a very very tricky check my bishops
is soulless promise no and I can take
check form am i mated here I almost
check I was thinking that maybe here i
can check no can put up some resistance
what i was trying to say but it's not
happening v6 is winning oh it says some
kind of tricks
not really yeah we should be success 95
okay so why he got as I got his revenge
gaming I certainly had my chance to step
I don't believe in this here for white
but it's um it's very tricky business
teak sticks a form yeah it took it the
engine gives me a slight advantage but
that this is very I mean as good as a
computer is but you need to give it a
little bit of time to especially those
long-term things with this pause maybe
maybe this this is awesome this is what
he is giving now maybe this is better
for Queen a 3 shack and so that's a
plausible continuation this is Lauren
yeah absolutely unclear the engine is on
zero stock version is on is on zero here
just acknowledging that nobody knows
what's going on yeah something like that
there were I mean tons of possibilities
maybe the Queen trade is wrong for
practical purposes because we get them
this end game type and here it is
definitely easier for wide to play and
probably objectively speaking white is
also better I think we we saw in the
game pretty m and pretty quickly um that
White's pawns here were too strong I
mean here yeah now I'm just losing him I
shouldn't have gone for that for that
end game but at the moment it wasn't
during the game I mean it wasn't so
clear to me that it was a it was a
questionable decision here you already
see that White's play is far too far too
dangerous yeah but a good game and
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching